In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadium for September 14, on which we commemorate, the pious
emperors Placilla, wife of the emperor Theliosios the Great, Saint Placilla, Aila Flavia
desired nothing more than to obtain the kingdom of heaven and took no pride at all in worldly power.
Even though she was the wife of Theliosios the Great in the years 379 through 395
and the mother of the emperor's Arcadius in the years 395 through 408 and onorios in the years 395
through 423. Giving thanks to God for the benefits he had showered on her, she devoted her energy
to visiting the poor and to tending the sick with her own hands, going to their homes unescorted.
She worked in the kitchens of hospices attached to churches, humbly doing all sorts of jobs,
not expected of a lady of royal dignity. She told people who tried to stop her that this was her
way of thanking God for the good things he had given her. She would tell her husband, Theliosios,
to give thanks to God at all times and to govern in accordance with the divine commandments.
Throughout her life St. Placilla served God in chastity, meekness, charity, and prayer
and departed in peace to eternal life in the year 386 or 385, having brought to those who encountered
her a pledge of the resurrection and of endless joy. Through the prayers of our Holy Father's
O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.